mr. speaker mr. speaker this is the most  significant vote that any of us will  ever be part of in our political careers  after after all the debates all the  disagreement all the division the time  has now come for all of us in this house  to make a decision a decision that will  define our country for decades to come a  decision that will determine the future  for our constituents their children and  their grandchildren a decision that each  of us will have to justify and live with  for many years to come  we know the consequences for voting for  this deal they are laid out in black and  white in the pages of the withdrawal  agreement but no one who votes against  this deal will be able to tell their  constituents what real-world outcome  they voted for because a vote against  this deal is a vote for nothing more  than uncertainty division and the very  real risk  [Applause]  I'm very great I'm very grateful for the  Prime Minister forgivingly Prime  Minister on any of the